>>Nick: Welcome everyone, to another Authors@Google
program at the San Francisco office.
Thanks so much for joining us.
We're very happy to have Dana Priest here.
She's an investigative reporter with the Washington
Post, but she's originally from California,
so welcome home.
>>Dana Priest: Thank you.
>>Nick: She's covered the intelligence, pentagon,
and health care areas for the Washington Post
and has won numerous awards including the
2008 Pulitzer Prize for her work on The Other
Walter Reed and the 2006 Pulitzer Prize for
beat reporting for her work on the CIA's secret
prisons and counter-terrorism operations overseas.
She's the author of the 2003 book, The Mission,
Waging War and Keeping Peace with America's
Military, and today she'll be discussing her
latest book, Top Secret America, The Rise
of the New American Security State.
Please welcome Dana Priest.
[applause]
>>Dana Priest: Thank you.
Ok.
Well thank you.
It's good to be home.
I'm trying to do this and one of my goals
this year was to figure out how to actually
use the iPad, so, I'm gonna give it a try.
I wanted to tell you a story about how, partly
how this book started.
And since you all, I know you all, everybody
warned me that you were gonna be on your computers
during this talk and I wasn't supposed to
be offended by it.
But I would like to give you a suggestion
about what you should be doing on your computer
while I'm talking to you, so if you go to
washingtonpost.com/topsecretamerica, you'll
see the website that initiated that is the,
the back that initiated the book.
It's a series that we did for the Post and
there's some great graphics, interactive graphics
that you can use, so once I explain what in
the heck we're doing and you wanna put your
ZIP code in or whatever, you can look around
there and play with it and hopefully not,
don't get too distracted.
While I was doing the work on the series,
I was in the Boise, Idaho, airport one day,
coming back from the Idaho Intelligence Fusion
Center, which is a place where the Department
of Homeland Security has funded intelligence
fusion centers in all the states and sometimes
more than one in each state, to begin putting
together the intelligence on counter-terrorism
or on terrorists.
And a lot of the places like Idaho don't really
have a lot of business in terrorism, so they
have turned it into looking for other kind
of crimes.
But anyway, I was in the airport and I saw
this elderly woman over near the security
scanner.
She was in a wheelchair and she was struggling
to get herself up out of the wheelchair and
gripping the sides of the scanner to go through
you know the security clearance thing, and
one of the guards, the TSA guards, was painfully
looking at her and you know said, "Oh, are
you ok?
Are you in pain?"
And she said, "No, I'm ok, I'm ok."
So I said I'll, I took my notebook out and
I went over there, I was already in my mindset
was, you know, this world had gotten so big
and it's so imprecise still and what keeps
us safer and what doesn't keep us safer?
And it sort of struck me as ludicrous that
this turns out to be 78-year-old grandmother
from Boise, Idaho, would have to get herself
out of her wheelchair and go through the security
scanner in order to make us safer.
So I went over to her and asked her, you know,
"What do you think about this hassle?"
And she said, "Oh, I don't mind it at all.
You know I could be a terrorist.
I could have explosives."
She, you know, wearing her bright white new
tennies and her flowered jacket, you know,
she was very happy.
But then all of a sudden she got really serious
and she said, "You know last time I went through
here they didn't even check."
And she opened her jacket and she said, "I
could've had a bomb."
[laughter]
>>Dana Priest: I'm thinking, well, maybe.
But the fact is no, you know no terrorist
has been found out through these sorts of
security scanners and no terrorist has ever
fit the profile of Joy Whiteman, her name
was, 78-year-old Joy Whiteman.
So is that a real good, good use of our money,
or what this became to me was a kind of perfect
metaphor for how to begin the book and how
to begin a process of questioning what is
it that we've done with, in the post-9/11
world, with all the money and with our own
fear about terrorism, what is it that we created?
And Joy Whiteman, in her struggle to get through
sort of exemplified that for me.
So what we did in order to answer some of
those questions is that my co-author and I,
Bill Arkin, [laughs] who would be just died
and gone to heaven to be here because he's,
he's one of you people.
[laughing] He and I separately had begun to
look at this world.
I began to look because I was covering the
intelligence community and I'd written about
the CIA's black sites, its covert operations
and how it was disappearing people after 9/11
in order to interrogate them.
And I had seen and met a lot of people from
organizations that were entirely new that
I had never heard of before and separately
Bill, working out of his barn in Vermont,
had been seeing the growth in a different
way.
He's a, he's a documents guy.
So he was collecting government contracts
for the intelligence world that you could
see, 'cause lots of it's classified.
And, and making lists and creating his own
databases and cross-referencing things, so
he was getting contracts, but he was also
getting more obscure contracts like the distribution
of electricity.
He got contracts for companies that would,
that would keep track of that for different
government agencies, so that if he saw something
on Google Maps, if he got pointed in that
direction through other research and he saw
something that he got, had a suspicion about
what it was, he would get the electricity
distribution of that county and he would find
that, oh, my God, there's like a huge amount
of energy being used at this place and then
in one instance he actually discovered through
that that this was a National Security Agency
downlink for its, its surveillance overseas
and what have you.
And then he would go on those super-secret
websites like Monster.com
[laughter]
>>Dana Priest: and type in, and you can do
this too now, if you want to, type in top
secret in its search engine and up came at
that time thousands of job descriptions for
people with top secret security clearances.
But not only that, it would have the job description
and it would have, depending on what company
it was, some hint of what they were doing.
And then in many cases it had five or six
code names for programs that they wanted that
person to be familiar with.
It didn't say what the code names meant, but
it said that there were code names.
And he began then, of course, he's a self-described
obsessive-compulsive person.
Best kind you know to be a researcher.
So he would make lists of the code names,
lists of the uses of electricity, lists of
contractors and contractees, and eventually
and he would begin to cross-reference all
of these and some of them began to make sense.
And then he would go to this other super-secret
website called LinkedIn, not quite a website,
but network, and find that there were people
who had security clearances who were not supposed
to be telling anybody what they did but they
were on LinkedIn and their biographies not
only told you what organizations they had
worked on but sometimes what code name programs
they were familiar with.
So for us that was a confirmation of, of these
sorts of things and in some cases the LinkedIn
bios confirmed some of the more secret organizations
that we'd discovered, because you know we'd
think well it's actually called Tosa, well
I don't know is that a real name or could
it be Tose?
And we would search LinkedIn and there would
be some guy there who said he had at one time
headed Tosa for such and such an agency.
When we got together and we decided that we
wanted to try to get our arms around the world
that was created in the military and intelligence
worlds after 9/11 to respond to the terrorists'
attacks, one of the things that we wanted
to do was to be able to show it to people.
And he was gonna be the one that quantified
it, or tried to, and I was gonna be the one
to get inside of it, talk to people inside,
put the, the flesh on the skeleton that we
were hoping to create with his data.
And one of the things we both had experiences
with was locating things.
I knew from my secret prisons experience that
everything, even if it's, if it's supposed
to be covert and never found, lives somewhere.
So we said well we should try to get addresses
and geo locate everything we find.
And it was painstaking, but we did that.
And we created what we call an alternative
geography of the United States.
Once we could put all these dots on our map,
we created a map of the United States that
we used to do our further reporting.
A version of the map is on our website.
And the version that's on the website excludes
a lot of information that we did, a lot of
detail that we learned, in part for security
reasons that we, that we thought about all
along the way.
So we want to tell people all we can about
this world, including making it real for them
so they don't have to rely on me, you know,
saying that it exists.
At the same time we want to be conscious of
some of the security implications.
So we have a map that that shows you the alternative
geography.
We also thought about it kind of like a genome
project that we were creating the DNA, we
were mapping the DNA of this secret world,
which was a fun way to think about it.
And then once we had the map and the addresses,
I should say that some of the addresses came
about because he would give me addresses to
go visit, but I would also find some of my
own and give 'em back to him and as we went
back and forth we found that, for instance,
if I went out to one place that he had given
me, then I would scope the whole area out
and end up giving him more addresses that
he would put back in his, in his database
and then go through his searches.
Google was helpful when we had an address
already because actually that's a huge, that
was the way that it was hugely helpful.
And also Google Maps was incredible because
we and we spent a lot of time on Google Maps
trying to, you know, once you could figure
out what the security looked like around a
place that was hiding in plain sight , you
could find all sorts of things that would
help you confirm whether you should keep going
or not or whether this was a total mislead.
But I first started, so we had this map that
we, or the map was developing.
I went out, so one of the, one of the hard
parts was trying to get inside the world because
of course we don't have clearances and we,
which would be a silly thing, because I'm
a reporter, I do the opposite of trying to
hide information, I'm always trying to share
it, in a responsible way.
So I convinced the Defense Intelligence Agency,
which is the largest of the intelligence agencies,
even though the CIA gets all the attention,
it's relatively small, to let me sit in on
a class that they were teaching on how do
you keep a secret conference, a top-secret
conference, how do you keep that information
from leaking out?
'Cause I, one of the things I wanted to do
was to, to show how onerous keeping secrets
is for the government.
So they let me come to the class, and it is
onerous.
I mean we did everything from, you know if
this were a secret meeting, figuring out you
know where to station the guards, how to take
your papers away from you, how to definitely
not let you bring any electronics into the
meeting.
If you did have notes you wanted to keep,
how to send them to you a way, in a secure
way through the, through snail mail, and they
use couriers to drop the things at the post
office, you know, it's just on and on to reverse
engineer that is an amazing thing, which,
which I did also.
But while we were there, I learned how to
set a zephyr lock, which is this electromagnetic
locks that are used to guard offices where
top secret information is going on.
I drove up to this place I'd never seen before
behind the Baltimore-Washington Airport, a
place that I have been many times, and I was
in this neighborhood that was really eerie.
It just had a, it wasn't, it wasn't, it was
subtly eerie, which is even more eerie in
a way.
[laughing] All the buildings look different,
you know, they, none of them had or few of
them had signs like where you were or what
company it represented.
Most of 'em had were of the same kind of architecture
and they had the same types of window film
on it and they had numbers on it instead of,
you know instead of the logos.
And so I started, I would keep my laptop in
the car with me and put it and open it up
usually to Google Maps, so that when Bill
was giving me addresses, you know, I could
find them on the map, but then here I am in
this place that looks so weird, and I'm driving
around and I'm giving him addresses and he's,
you know, he's looking at it from his barn
in Vermont on the maps and giving me, you
know, oh go here, go there.
And what it, what it turned out to be was
I was sitting in what we later identified
as or called the Capital of Top Secret America.
Which is not in Washington D.C., it's actually
north of Washington in Fort Mead, which is
where the National Security Agency resides.
And the NSA is one of the largest intelligence
agencies.
It is involved in surveillance, electronic
surveillance of every kind, mostly overseas,
but increasingly also in the United States
with the proper authorities.
And so this thing that I had stumbled upon
was the densest part of Top Secret America.
And it was not only these government buildings
that were there, but contractors that were
there.
And we learned later as we as this world woke
up to us as we could see what was all around
us in a different way, that you had a clustering
effect throughout the country.
And the clusters would be clustered around
a government, a big government agency, but
then sub-agencies would come and grow up near
the big agency, the ones that worked with
it and then companies would relocate and develop
around them too, because they were now the
growing contractor base, which we knew existed,
but we didn't know to what extent it existed
and that was also what we were trying to document.
So for this cluster that we're talking about
here at the National Security Agency, it was
so visible if you turned down the right streets
and I found the right streets because as I
exited from the freeway to get into this location,
I was, you know my reporter's antenna was
really up, and, meaning I don't know what
I'm gonna find, I'm looking at everything
trying to just you know have all my senses
aware and I see a lawn sign, you know the
kind of lawn signs that you see that says
Townhouses $400,000 and up?
Only this lawn sign said, Joe's Café, Job
Fair, Cleared Personnel, TS/SCI, which means
top secret/secure compartmented information,
which is above top secret.
And so I went to Joe's Café and it was like
this divey café like you see all over the
place, but instead of posters for you know
the newest kind of coffee or whatever, it
had information, it had Lockheed Martin and
General Dynamics and Khaki and SAIC posters
for job positions and the little coffee holder
didn't have like Google on it, it had you
know it had Carahsoft, which is a company
that does top secret work in the IT space
for the government.
So when I got there I noticed that right across
the street there was a big business park.
And so I drove around the business park and
it was a business park, turns out, of the
biggest contractors in Top Secret America.
I mean I didn't know that at the time, I was
just writing everything down.
Huge, hundreds of acres of business, corporation
after corporation, giant gleaming new buildings,
and of course I copied down every logo I could
find.
And unlike the places nearer to the nation's
capital where these companies operate where
they keep a rather low profile, they'll have
like the little logo on top as you're driving
down some of the main highways you'll see
them all over the place.
Here, since nobody except the people inside
ever come there, you wouldn't know to come
there, it's kind of hidden behind trees, it
was like they were showing their flag and
the logos were bigger and brighter and you
know they were saying here we are and they
even had a, a, a private bridge between the
business park and the National Security Agency
which only they could use, so they could have
direct access.
So when we began to think about contractors,
we, one of the things we did was we looked
at every agency and figured out how many contractors
work for it at the top secret level and at
the NSA there were greater number than anywhere
else.
There was something over 400.
So I wanna stop for one second and show you,
can you still hear me?
[chuckles] Or maybe Nick will run it.
>>Nick: I can do it When you're ready, just
give me the thumbs up.
>>Dana Priest: One of the things we wanted
to do before you turn that on is I wanted--.
As a journalist I was getting very frustrated
by the fact that I thought the platform was
driving the content, you know everyone was
so mesmerized and and baffled by the multi-platforms
that you could present your material on and
we were far behind in trying to figure out
how to use that, so I thought that the platforms
were really driving what a lot of journalists
did, which was making me really mad, because
I think that the content should drive, you
know the platforms should serve the content.
And so I was, I was convinced that I could
use this project to show that the platforms
could deepen the reporting experience and
the information sharing.
So we started from the very start this would
be a multi, a multi-media project and that's
why we had the website, but we also did a
video that is supposed to make it simpler
to understand what you were gonna read and,
and here's the, here's the video.
[music starts]
>>video narrator: You think you know America,
but you don't know Top Secret America.
We're all aware that there are three branches
of government in the United States, but in
response to 9/11, a fourth branch has emerged.
It is protected from public scrutiny by extraordinary
secrecy.
Top Secret America.
>>William M. Arkin, reporter: This is a closed
community and since 9/11 it's become even
more so.
>>Dana Priest: The money spigot was just opened
after 9/11 and nobody dared say, "I don't
think we should be spending that much."
>>video narrator: It has become so big and
the lines of responsibility are so blurred
that even our nation's leaders don't have
a handle on it.
Where is it?
It's being built from coast to coast, hidden
within some of America's most familiar cities
and neighborhoods, in Colorado, in Nebraska,
in Texas, in Florida, in the suburbs of Washington
D.C.
Top Secret America includes hundreds of federal
departments and agencies operating out of
1300 facilities around this country.
They contract the services of nearly 2000
companies.
In all, more people than live in our nation's
capital have top secret security clearance.
>>Dana Priest: It's again the size, the, the
lack of transparency and the cost.
And if we don't get it right, the consequences
are gigantic.
>>Dana Priest: Can you stay up there for a
minute and do the photos?
Ok.
[music ends]
>>Dana Priest: So I have some other audio
visuals.
This world began right after 9/11 when congress
and everyone else was panicked that there
was gonna be another attack.
And what congress did was to write a blank
check.
It was actually $40 billion, but you know
what the heck?
Close to a blank check because weeks later
they gave them another $40 billion, and the
money spigot just continued in that vein.
And it was for anything you know that they
thought would help.
So all intelligence agencies and a lot of
the military and law enforcement agencies
came up with all sorts of ideas.
And the problem, I think, is that nobody every
stopped and said, you know years later when
they figured out that there weren't 100 Al-Qaeda
sleeper cells in the United States, nobody
stopped to say, you know, let's reassess.
What's working and what's not working?
So when it started to grow, they said, well
we better get a manager here to manage all
this growth.
So congress, and with the President's support,
passed legislation that created somebody,
an office and a person that was supposed to
be the manager of the whole darn thing, which
is called the National, the Director of National
Intelligence.
But because it was congress and none of the
committees wanted to give up any of their
power over certain agencies, they didn't actually
give him the authority to do the job that
they said they wanted him to do.
They, he couldn't even hire and fire, much
less tell some organization as big as the
Defense Department what it was and wasn't
gonna do and Donald Rumsfeld was the Defense
Secretary and he wasn't gonna let any other
government official take a large chunk of
his power away either, so it became a feckless
organization from the beginning.
It's gotten better in some regards, but not
in others, but one thing it has done is grown
and so this is a building that you're not
supposed to see because it's a, an undeclared
location.
It's located in some of the toniest real estate
market in the Washington area, Fairfax County.
The photographer that took this picture, this
is in the winter, so as you can see the trees
don't have leaves on 'em, and he found a,
after I scouted it out, I mean I knew where
it was 'cause I'd been there.
But you know I scouted out a place that he
could take pictures from that was on public
property.
And even though he was on public property,
he tells the story about going and doing it
and having people seemingly drop out of the
trees with black, you know, uniforms on and
big guns and [laughing].
They didn't confiscate his camera, but they
almost did, and they didn't, he was quick
to, to take the chip out of his camera before
they got to the car so they didn't get his
photos.
I mean, c'mon, we're not talking about, we're
talking about a huge building that hundreds,
thousands of people work in.
We got, so, in order, they wouldn't tell us
how many people worked there, so in order
to figure out how big it really is we got
the, the contractor that built the building
was very proud of building the building and
said it was 500,000 square feet.
[laughter]
>>Dana Priest: And when I was there I spent
some of my time before and after the interviews
driving around the parking lots, there are
two giant parking lots, counting the parking
spaces to figure out, ok, how many people
come to work every day.
[chuckles] So that's pretty much how we found
out that it was that big.
It's the equivalent of stacking five Wal-Marts
on top of each other.
And so it's gigantic and then you have to
say, ok, what goes on inside that is really
keeping us safer?
And this is one of the co-, one of the agencies,
there are about three or four of them, big
agencies, that people who work inside the
intelligence world are always criticizing
for adding no value to the effort.
But, as you see, it's grown really larger.
How 'bout the next one?
We'll run through these pretty quick.
This is on the website that I was talking
to you about and it's, it's just the, it's
just the subset, it's the Washington area.
But what I like about it and you can see it
better on the website are the buildings that
are circling it.
Buildings became the symbol for this world
and how we could measure the world if we're
outsiders.
They were, they became important because you
could see them if you found them, you could
take pictures of them.
But they're also permanent.
These buildings are built to last.
And that says something important about this
whole enterprise, it's built to last a long
time.
So here we've just listed the 33 largest buildings
in the Washington area and we could get square
footage for all of them in the same way and
they turn out to be three times larger, they
equal three Pentagons.
Which, I don't know if you've seen that, but
it's an enormous building.
So just the 33 big ones equal in their space
3 Pentagons.
This is that job fair sign that I was telling
you about, Joe's Café.
This is actually the NSA building at night,
which I got a lot of the details about that
because they are expanding and the county
had a lot of records on the environmental
impact of the expanding, including it had
this fun detail about how large their parking
lot is, it's like 125 acres and you could
get somewhat of a sense.
But it's an organization that has doubled
in size since 9/11 as most of the intelligence
agencies have.
Ok.
And this is what's right across from it.
This is just one company, Booz Allen Hamilton,
in that business park I was talking to you
about.
So I went there at night, got followed by
the NSA security police the whole time, drove
slowly, didn't make any sudden moves, but
you could get a sense of how big it is and
it just went on also for a mile square probably.
Ok.
And then the issue of contractors and what
they do for the government came up.
The law says they're supposed to do, they're
not supposed to do inherent governmental functions.
So they're really supposed to be there for
support, administrative, IT, other things.
But the reality is they do everything.
And this is my favorite example.
This is the wall at the CIA where people who
died in the line of duty, there's a star carved
for them.
And this man is the stone carver who's carving
a couple more stars for people who died after
9/11.
There are 22 stars for people who were killed
in the line of duty after 9/11 and of the
22, 8 of them are contractors.
So that tells you that contractors are doing
not just support work kind of on the periphery,
but they're in the core of what the government
does.
And both Donald Rumsfeld, or both Robert Gates,
Defense Secretary at the time, and Leon Panetta,
CIA Director at the time I interviewed them
for this, had great concerns about how to
get that under control.
Panetta said that he was worried that the
contractors' first alliance, allegiance was
to their companies, their profit-making companies.
Not to dis profit, but if, you know, what
company is ever gonna say, "No, we really
don't need that contract, it's not gonna get
you anywhere."
It just doesn't work that way.
Bill, Bob Gates told me the story when I was
interviewing him of trying, a story that he
said "was embarrassing to tell, but I'll tell
you anyway" of trying to get the number of
contractors that work in his own personal
office, the office of Secretary of Defense,
which is a big office, there are hundreds
of people there.
But he couldn't get it.
He asked his staff, "How many contractors
work here?" and they couldn't tell him.
And that's in part because contractors hire
subcontractors and there's not a record of
who all the subcontractors are and that's
created a situation that the government really
at any one time can't tell you how many contractors
work for it.
We estimated out of the nearly 900,000 people
with top secret clearances that 250,000 of
them, a quarter of a million people, were,
were contractors, so a huge, you know, it's
a huge deal and these days most of these agencies
they couldn't even function without the contractors.
The Department of Homeland Security, that,
they run on more contractors than federal
employees.
So you know it's a huge part of what they
do.
Finally, well let's see, what's the next?
Oh, the contractors have a good time with
their government officials.
This is, this is a just a fun photo from the,
a Phoenix conference that I visited.
It was a conference put on by the Defense
Intelligence agency.
And the contractors that were there were trying
to you know sell their wares to the government
officials, and this is a party put on by one
of them at which they were schmoozing, you
know having a good time with their government
people.
This is another of the hubs that, ok, this
is the whole map.
We didn't go down very far, we went down to
the to search city/state couplets is as far
down as we could go, or not could go, we decided
to go because of again the security concerns.
And I never really thought the map was as
good as it could be because I wanted to have
those, you guys, I'm hoping you'll appreciate
this, but I really did wanna have, like, dots
stacked on top of each other so you could
see the density instead.
The cartologists said, "No, if we can't be
exactly precise, we're not gonna pretend to
be, you know, pretend to represent something."
We had these big theological debates about,
[chuckles] about it, and they won.
But the other thing, [laughs] the other thing
is on the side, on the left side is one of
my favorite discoveries, which is of the,
of the top, I think that's there.
Oh no, that's not there, ok.
Well, somewhere on that website is one of
my favorite discoveries, which was that of
the top, of the ten wealthiest counties in
the United States, this is Census Bureau data,
six of them are located in the most densest
clusters of Top Secret America.
So you see the ripple effect of the, of this
growth is not just that government's getting
bigger and companies are getting bigger, but
the you know disparity between the Washington
region and the rest of the country you can
actually see.
And all of those, each of those six counties
are, have a lot of Top Secret America intelligence
work and agencies there.
Ok, I think we have just a couple more.
So the other thing that's happening, this
is Memphis, Tennessee, Real Time Crime Center.
And the other thing that's happened is that
we're not just talking about the federal government,
but all of this is trickling down in a different
form to the states and to local communities.
And this Crime Center, which has just walls
of video screens connected to hundreds of
cameras that are set up throughout Memphis
to watch people.
It was funded in part by the Department of
Homeland Security.
And what they want to do now, they're on a
couple camp, they're on a big campaign, it's
called See Something, Say Something.
And it is what I, what I call a dragnet approach
to, to counter-terrorism, one that has no
track record by the way.
However, it's one that they are pushing with
a lot of, they're pushing aggressively, and
they're funding it.
So they're trying to get the states to not
only build these fusion centers, but to turn
the local police and sheriff's departments
into the eyes and ears for the FBI, into tipsters.
And they're doing it not only by, by giving
them money to use certain technology and to
build certain things like these real time
crime centers, but also through grants for
technology.
And the technology that seems to be more pervasive,
is technology that was developed for the battlefield,
but is migrating to the United States as companies
find that there's a market here for things
that helped soldiers figure out whether the
neighborhood was filled with neighbors that
belonged there or insurgents that didn't belong
there.
Things like biometric and standoff biometrics,
where you know they can fingerprint people
from a, remotely from a distance so you don't
even know it's happening, or mobile fingerprint
scanners so that if you get stopped at a for
a traffic violation they can ask you to give
you, give them your fingerprints.
Or, what I think is more powerful and less
and less viewed as, well it's just more powerful
and less known, is the, the databases that
are being created to fuse, to bring together
different types of information and to mine
that for nuggets that will point to abnormal
patterns or that will pull out an individual.
Part of the, one kind of database that's emerged
and is in the book is the FBI's Guardian Database
and it's filled with, the DHS is undertaking
a they have these things called Suspicious
Activity Reports, SARs, and they want local
police but also citizens to fill them out
if they see something, if they see somebody
doing something that's suspicious, that could
be an indicator of terrorism.
There's one, there's one county, I think it's
in Texas, which has actually developed an
app, so that if you get the app and then you
see somebody who's suspicious you could write
out, you can fill it out right then and there
and click and mail it in to the Department
of Homeland Security of that state and they
can maybe act on it.
There's a reference in the book to a family
who was Middle-Eastern looking and they were
taking a picture of a fireboat at in the Balboa
harbor and they are now in this, in the database
because if you're driving a car that has your
registration on it it's easy for the police
to you know note that.
But the databases also, they, it can accumulate
a lot of information about you if you have
no criminal record.
If you do have a criminal record, it's gonna
have that in it for sure, but if you don't
because of another trend, which is just the
trend in coll-, in companies collecting private
information on people which the government
can now buy, just like the Washington Post
can buy it to help me do my reporting, but
the government can now buy a lot of the privacy
informa-, a lot of the private information
and without a warrant like it needed before
without probable cause that maybe you had
actually, not maybe but they thought it was
probable that you had done something wrong,
now they can fill their database and your
dossier with with some of this information
without getting a warrant.
So the databases are growing and you know
once you have a database with a lot of cool
data, you're gonna figure out what, [chuckles]
how to, how to use it, you're gonna try to
mine it in different ways, this is sort of
the, I think you know this better than I do,
but kind of the nature of the beast.
If you've got raw data sitting around why
not you know play with it?
Let's see, I think we got a, we have a couple
more photos.
So there's another example of the kind of
technology that came from the battlefield.
This is the automatic license plate reader
which allows police to drive by and their,
their cameras will automatically import the
license plates around them, run the criminal
checks, I was sitting in the car with this
guy who'd developed this for Memphis, and
they could tell so many different things about
the driver of the vehicle.
So if they had a warrant it would kind of
go 'boing', and they could pull them over
and make them pay or send them to jail if
you had an outstanding warrant.
If it was a, my favorite was convicted gangster,
that's what they called them.
[laughter]
>>Dana Priest: I wasn't quite sure what gangster
meant, but [laughing] and it would you know
go like 'rrrrrrrrrrrrrr'.
And then of course they had convicted child
molester and gang member and drug dealer and
all that.
So really can do a lot with that kind of thing.
Before I take your questions, let me just
get through a couple more photos and then
we can open it up for questions.
>>Nick: That's it.
>>Dana Priest: Ok.
Oh, perfect timing.
You had a question in the back.
>>male #1: Yeah, actually I was just kind
of curious, it seems, um, um, obviously be
guessing about how big the government's growing
and should they have all these tools?
I'm wondering what your opinion is about,
is, is this too much?
Is this--
>>Dana Priest: Ok.
The question was it seems like we're guessing
about how big it is but do we have an opinion
about whether the big, the, the largeness
is good and effective?
I'm really not guessing.
I mean we, we, we wanted to put together,
we wanted to document this in a way that was
evidence based.
Yeah.
So, and, yes, the book and I do have an opinion
on it, and it comes from people on the inside
who were really helpful who were very discouraged
by what they were seeing.
And so the bottom line is I think that we're
a lot safer than we were on 9/11, but it's
not because of this giant thing that we've
created that we call Top Secret America.
It is because there are organizations, they
tend to be relatively small, within this group
of organizations, that have done some amazing
work and just to tell you what they are, probably
won't be any surprise, but domestically the
FBI's counter-terrorism agents, that's where
terrorism, that's where potential terrorists
have been identified.
By people who understand what they're doing
and have been doing it for a long time.
Overseas the CIA analysts who ended up finding
the Bin Laden compound?
Those people, relatively small group, laser-focused
on their mission, have been doing it for a
long time.
The special operations troops that we write
a whole chapter about them, they're really
a secret army that is grown up after 9/11
and has maintained more secrecy around it
than even the CIA's paramilitary operations.
They, if, if what you want is a group of people
to go and capture and kill, find, capture
and kill likely terrorists, they're the people
you want to do it because they do it very
effectively.
Their, their, their raids are about 50 percent
accurate according to sources inside, which
doesn't sound that great, but it's better
than a lot of other military organizations
and there's always a cost to them.
If they kill the wrong people there's huge
blow-back to those and there have been a lot
of blow-back on these very secretive operations.
So yes, I think we are safer, but not because
of this giant thing.
And in fact the giant thing is imploding on
itself.
In part because it's so big and people with
inside don't even know, you know, what else
is inside.
>>male #1: Also, what's your opinion of Wikileaks
and Julian Assange and do you have any thoughts
about that?
>>Dana Priest: So two different questions,
first of all.
You know, I met Julian before all the hoopla
and I would say that I'm not a great fan personally
and I think that his, his, some of his anti-American
statements are, are not helpful and you know,
whatever, wrong-headed.
However, I think the revelations that have
come out of the Wikileaks and the idea that
there is such an organization that at least
is an anti-secrecy organization should not
be discounted at all and that we, and that
those documents provided some of the most
interesting revelations about our own government
in a long time.
Do I think that you know he's damaged national
security like some government officials have
claimed?
We haven't seen that yet.
It could be.
He was very sloppy in the beginning.
I think he didn't even understand how outing
government documents could put lives at risk,
like the lives of sources.
I know some of the reporters who worked with
him on the first tranche of, of articles who
did know, because they had worked in this
field for a long time, and, and one of them
said, you know we took our baseball bats out
at the very end before publication to drill
into him that you had to be responsible with
this information because there were things
that should not be public because it will
put people's lives at risk.
So I think the in general the government's
overreacted tremendously to Wikileaks in an
uh.
But the other interesting thing about Wikileaks
which I write about in the book, is the government's
done a counterintelligence assessment of this,
like how did it happen?
How vulnerable are we?
How vulnerable are our documents?
Because one of the things they quickly discovered
was that the State Department, where all these
cables came from, you know they, they put
a lot out on their, on their secret network,
called SIPRNet and, and it's easy to access
or it was at the time.
I mean, it's easy, it was very easy to access
if you had that level of classification and
it shouldn't have been as easy as it was.
And they did that because they have no clue
what they're doing.
And that's what the the assessment found.
The assessment found that government agencies
that are supposed to be keeping secrets don't
have a clue, by and large, of how easy it
is for people to break in or to get access
and not really need to have access.
The, the conclusion of the book has this very
fun, I, fun in my perverted way, this, this
fun parallel universe of on the one hand the
government after 9/11 cracked down on public
information, declared a war on terrorism once
it was declared a war you know everything
was secret because it could aid the enemy.
At the same time, technology marches on and
I, I go up and interview the, the guys at
a company, a pretty small company called Traversa,
that works for private companies trying to
find their proprietary information that's
made its way out of the company's secured
site for various reasons, usually because
employees bring their work home and usually
because their kids have file share software
and then that's like opening your door to
your house and there are all these people
that do nothing more than go into houses looking
for interesting files.
And so they've found what they call the tuna
in the, the dolphin in the tuna nets, they've
found a lot of government classified information
out there because people working for the government
have put it out there unknowingly.
That's to say that while the government's
scurrying around trying to keep you from information
that I at least think is in the public interest
to know, to know whether our government's
on the right course or not, technology is
making that all obsolete in a, in a certain
ad hoc way.
And the people who study this inside government
know it.
They know that they are losing this battle
and that there's this involuntary transparency
that's occurring that Wikileaks best, best
symbolizes.
So even people whose job it is to keep out,
to keep information from falling into the
wrong hands, now believe that there's no way
they can win in that situation and that the
only way to really, the only way to really
work with it is to declassify many government
secrets and to reassess what secrecy means
and to keep secret only what really needs
to be kept secret and to do it in a way that
you know you can maintain that secrecy, because
as this project shows you, you know, it's,
it's hard to keep a secret these days.
So with that I think this is a good point
to take more questions.
Ok.
Yeah.
>>male #2: You haven't mentioned the left
or the right in terms of political responsibility,
so I'm curious, like, how much of this came
under the Bush administration, granted that
was closer to when 9/11 happened.
>>Dana Priest: Yeah.
>>male #2: How much has been either added
on to that or reversed under Obama?
>>Dana Priest: So it all grew up under, under
President Bush.
All the, a lot of the, most of the agencies
that we write about, most of the legal interpretations
that allowed organizations like the Special
Operations to, to do what they do and in that
certain way.
But most of it has been continued under Obama.
He came in talking about transparency, talking
about the rule of law and disbanding some
of the more controversial things.
By and large he's not done any of that and
he's taken the Bush blueprint for counter-terrorism
overseas and run with it.
He's increased the lethal drone strikes and
he has increased the number of organizations
that work in Top Secret America by allowing
those, by allowing the individual agencies
to create more of them and by not stepping
back and assessing, you know, where are we
now?
What is really the threat, which I think is
step number one, is to have the government
speak more honestly with us about the threat.
There are several hundred Al-Qaeda left because
those organizations I was talking to you about
before were effective in killing them off.
And, yes, there have been new affiliates that
have sprung up, but the more effective organizations
within this world, they have a, a good read
on them and they're, you know, likely to defeat
them, too.
So we don't have, but we aren't given the
opportunity to know much, still about what
is the real threat so you can then say, ok,
if this is the threat, this is what it looks
like, what are we willing to spend on that?
It's the basic risk analysis and, and we're
not there yet in part because it's not politically,
it's a bad idea to bring it up if you're a
member, if you're an elected official, one
side or the other is gonna call you soft on
terrorism and then if there's another plot
or a plot that's un, you know, that's stopped
even, but if there's a smaller incident that
happens, you know, you'll be blamed.
And so I think that even the public has to
take some responsibility for not engaging
in an honest discussion of what all this costs,
what's it worth, what is the threat?
Because we're part of the problem in that
every time something might happen, you know,
you can bet that the media for sure is gonna
say you know, "Who's at fault here?"
And the answer, the solution to all of that
is more.
More money, more agents, more contractors,
more analysis papers, more, more, more.
[chuckles] And I'd argue that that's not the
right approach anymore.
Right behind you.
>>male #3: So you, you talk a lot about how
you took very, very necessary precautions
to avoid publishing anything that could be
damaging.
>>Dana Priest: Right.
>>male #3: Was that, was that part of your
core philosophy originally or, or how much
of that was affected by the last, the last
week in, the last week of August when David
Leigh's book on Wikileaks published the encryption
key for all of the unredacted cables?
>>Dana Priest: Oh, what you just mentioned
came out long before, I mean came out after
all these decisions were made.
No, it comes from my work on in the intelligence
and military world where I come across information
that's pretty sensitive sometimes and every
time that that happens we have an unofficial
procedure in which we, you know I'll get to
the point of having finished a story that
has that information in, I'll call the government
up, I'll tell them what I have, so that they,
if they want to, they can make a case that
something shouldn't be published.
But the decision is my editor's, or the editor
of the Washington Post.
But we need to know what the concern is in
order to even make a decision about it.
And sometimes you're, you have something that
you know is sensitive, but you might not know
how sensitive, so the government engages in
a discussion with the paper over these issues
and, but the paper makes the final decision.
So in the secret sites, the black sites, the
editor, you know, which went all the way up
to the President, and our editor decided that
we would, we would put all the story in the
paper except we wouldn't name the countries.
We had several countries where we knew the
prisons were, but we named the region, which
was Eastern Europe.
So that's the sort of trade off.
Is that it?
Ok.
>>Nick: Well, I think we have to end it, but
please join me in thanking Dana Priest for
coming.
[applause]